I've got pairs of mixed numbers and
improper fractions and I want to think
about which of the two is larger so one
in seven eights 39 over 10 so you could
do this in your head you could say 10
goes into 39 I'll even write out 10 goes
into 39 3 times 3 times 10 and you want
to find the largest number of times 10
goes into this without going over so if
you couldn't write a 4 over here because
then that would be 40 that would go over
39 3 times 10 is 30 and then you have a
remainder of 9 so you could rewrite this
expression right over here instead of 39
over 10 you could write it as 30 over 10
plus 9 over 10 and 30 over 10 is just 3
so this is equal to 3 and 9/10 and you
could do that in your head you could say
10 goes into 39 3 times and the
remainder is 9
you have your 9/10 and that's
essentially just doing this in your head
so now we can compare and we can
literally just look at the whole number
part this is 1 and something 1 in 7
eighths and we're comparing it to
essentially 3 and nine-tenths
3 and 9/10 is clearly a larger number we
have a 3 out here instead of a 1 so we
will write less than and the way I
always remember it is the opening always
faces the larger number the opening is
large it faces the larger number and the
point is small it always points to the
smaller number now let's do this next
one four and 7/8 versus 49 over 9 so
let's convert this to a mixed number
nine goes into 49 five times and 5 times
9 is 45 so the remainder is going to be
4
the remainder is 4 so this is 5 and 4/9
once again we can literally just look at
the whole number parts 5 is clearly
larger than 4 so once again less than
point facing the smaller number opening
facing and the larger number now
two-and-a-half versus 11 tense 10 goes
into 11 only one time and if you care
about the remainder it's 1 so it's 1 and
1/10 which is clearly smaller than 2 and
1/2 you just look at the whole number
parts 2 is clearly larger than 1 so we
want our opening the of
our less-than or greater-than sign to
face the the larger number so we would
write it like this and this is greater
than so two and a half is greater than
eleven tenths the little point facing
the smaller number 5 and 4/9 versus 47
47 7 goes into 40 so let me rewrite this
7 goes into 40 five times and then
you're going to have a remainder of 5
because 7 times 5 is 35 you have a
remainder of 5 to get to 40 so it's five
and five sevens and if that looks like
I'm doing some type of Voodoo just
remember I'm really just breaking it up
I'm just really saying that 40 over
seven is the same thing as 35 plus five
over seven the largest multiple of seven
that is less than this number and this
is the same thing as 35 over seven plus
five sevens and then this 35 over seven
is five and five sevenths is just five
sevenths there this one is interesting
because we have the same whole number
out front on our mixed numbers five
versus five so now we actually do have
to pay attention to the fractional part
of our mixed number we essentially have
to compare 4/9 for nine to five sevens
and there's a couple of ways to do this
you could get them to have the same
denominator that's probably the easiest
way to do it so you could rewrite so
what's the least common multiple of nine
and seven they share no factors so
really the least common multiple is
going to be their product so if we want
to rewrite 4/9 we would write 63 in the
denominator that's nine times seven if
we multiply the denominator by seven we
also have to multiply the numerator by
seven so that will be 28 now 5/7 we're
going to make the denominator 63 we're
multiplying the denominator times nine
then we have to multiply the numerator
times nine as well five times nine is
forty-five
so here it's easy to see 45 over 63 is
clearly larger than 28 over 63 and so we
could write this and because the whole
number of parts are the same and 5/7 is
the same thing as 45 45 60 thirds and
4/9 is the same thing as 2860 thirds we
can write it that 5 and 4/9 is less than
40 over 7 another way that you could
have thought about 4 ninths versus 5/7
you could have said well how does 4/9
how does 4/9 compared to 4/7 we have the
same numerator the denominator here is
large in the denominator here but when
you have number in the denominator the
larger it is a smaller the fraction the
smaller the absolute value of the
fraction so this right over here is a
smaller quantity than four sevens and
4/7 is clearly a smaller quantity than
5/7
so 4/9 is clearly smaller than 5/7 so we
would have gotten the same result